i don't you have to tell me why britain
hasn't recognized the armenian genocide
i would say that
there are too many cozy relationships
with bp azerbaijan turkey having to do
with the gas corridor the southern gas
corridor
and it's basically playing geopolitics
and using genocide as political capital
which is disgusting
the armenian genocide has been something
that you know i've
i've learned from my grandparents all
four member all four grandparents
of mine are survivors of the armenian
genocide and if her
growing up heard their horrific stories
about how their families perished and
and what they had to live through and
you know my my grandfather grew up as an
orphan you know
the reason i was born in lebanon is
because of the armenian genocide
because we were displaced as a people
the majority of armenians live in a
diaspora outside of armenia because of
the genocide
um it's a huge uh national
grieving for us you know system of then
also put on to put out two songs during
the
uh art war in arsenal as a way of
bringing attention
to the truth of what was actually
happening and to fight azerbaijan
disinformation and bots on social media
we've also gathered a large amount of
money
to donate to nonprofits in armenia
for uh retrofitting soldiers with uh
prosthetics who had lost prosthetics to
uh drone attacks
um as well as laser therapy for soldiers
suffering from white phosphorus banned
weapon weaponry burns
dropped by the azeri army